welcome to see each hat hosted by cloud
on-air live webinars from Google cloud
just a reminder we are hosting these
webinars every Tuesday my name is J
Smith I'm a cloud customer engineer here
at Google and today I will be talking to
Dave Berra - nice thank you very much
today we're going to be talking a little
bit about cube flow and just as a
reminder guys we will we encourage you
to ask questions anytime on the platform
and we have Googlers on standby to
answer them and we'll get to some of
them at the end as well so let's get
started great thanks for watch Jay as
you mentioned we're here to talk about
cube flow that's machine learning on
kubernetes or as we like to say cloud
native ml and I think it's a really
interesting time to be talking about
machine learning and kubernetes together
the reality is is that everyone hears
about how great ml is they want to adopt
it and and you know immediately make
changes to their business and I think
the problems that a lot of people have
today is it can be very complicated and
there's a big distance between the
actual vision of ml and getting it going
off the ground a lot of people today you
know say ml is great they hear about it
it's in the news they hear it from their
colleagues and friends they want to go
and solve a bunch of problems very
definitely a big buzzword and
everybody's trying to invest in it
absolutely and and the reason is is
because of things like this this is
something that Google did specifically
this is Google engineers Google data
scientists who spend their entire life
getting great at data centers using
renewable energy using the latest
technologies and then they go and they
attach an ml solution to the problem to
handle the power and cooling and
management of their data centers and
almost instantly they were able to save
40% a huge amount of money by attaching
machine learning models to these
frameworks so they were able to make a
huge difference
already better than the
in in almost any industry just by using
this machine learning technology and
this is something that a lot of
industries are really excited about and
they were like well geez you know I'd
love to get some of that as well
unfortunately machine learning is very
hard and it's not just because I'm
terrible at math it is because this is
the reality of machine learning on one
side you have that magical AI goodness
which is so easy to see where the
benefits are so powerful and on the
other side you see where most folks are
today they they you know have you know
old-style legacy infrastructure they
need to integrate with they have very
large data sets that they're trying to
manage and maintain and make the most
use of and there's so much distance
between machine you know where they are
today and the magical AI goodness in the
future well that's pretty extensive
they're just not a magic wand like a lot
of us think just throw good throw
pictures and get a result yeah no
question there's there's there really is
no magic wand and the reason is there's
no magic wand is because you basically
have this reality there are two sides of
the world side one is where you have
these do-it-yourself solutions where you
set it up from scratch where you
integrate with legacy systems and then
once you've finally done all that work
which can be you know weeks months years
in order to do that you often have to do
it all over again as you need to migrate
as you change your solution as anything
in your system overall changes the other
side of the coin is around hosted and I
should say this is not all hosted
solutions but certainly this is the
trend in the first five minutes it looks
great you're immediately able to make
progress a change the way you do your
business and and and at least experiment
with the model but then in the next five
years you face everything you did in the
do-it-yourself scenario you have the
same you know customization issues you
have the same legacy systems that you
need to integrate plus now you're locked
in you've used a framework or a model
that only works on a single cloud and
you're kind of out of luck so the
question is haven't we heard this story
before
and the reality is we have before I came
to work on cube flow I ended up I was
working on the kubernetes platform and
kubernetes when it first came out in
2015 it was very very similar story the
reality was that containers and
kubernetes in 2015 and before was a
highly bespoke solution you had to come
up with a lot of custom tooling
frameworks and so on in order to get
things up and running and and in order
to wire everything together it became an
enormous amount of work you had to have
entire teams dedicated to that when
kubernetes came along in 2015 you now
started to have a standard set of api's
and in native ways to handle the
complexities of distributed computing
and that really changed the game people
started to leverage the the kubernetes
native platform to go to the next level
off in in cube con austin 2017 in last
December we talked about some of the
ways that that we really have started to
unlock that future right you guys were
just a cube Connie you as well all right
that's absolutely right and and the way
that we were able to unlock that that
future was with these native extension
points you have all these various
components that that operate in layers
from all those runtimes and plugins
moving up the stack to the new API layer
application layer governance layer so on
and so forth but each of these had very
clean lines and they enabled people to
swap out the things that made the most
sense for running kubernetes and what
that ultimately resulted in is people
being able to run cloud native
applications applications for running
containers that used all the stat things
that were provided to them without any
customization and so what we would like
to propose around machine learning is
cloud native ml a similar approach to
the system which adopts the core
components of what makes containers and
kubernetes so strong that is
composability portability and
scalability so for each of those I think
it's worth just a moment to talk about
how they apply to machine
when you think about composability first
you think about building a model around
your machine learning solution and
that's certainly something very
interesting
whether or not it's tensorflow cafe CMT
km x net pi torch you name it there are
many many different ways to build a
model and people get very excited about
that but the reality is when it comes to
building a machine learning solution it
ends up being much much more than that
you end up having all these various
components that you need to integrate
and each of those components are often
slightly different based on the data
scientist working on it that's
definitely not a non magic there that is
a lot of work and a lot of knowledge and
a lot of skills needed right to make any
of this work right yeah so and and I
think that's exactly right
data scientists get have skills in
particular areas they want to use the
frameworks that are familiar to them the
tools that are familiar of them in each
of these various stages from data to
experimentation to production and
ultimately rolling it out and I think
that that really speaks to how you have
to have these things be composable so if
you have a data scientist in one
organization they can use standard
techniques and then swap them for a
different set of techniques for a
different data scientist in a different
work all right so that's kind of
category one we want them to be
composable and let people choose what
makes sense then category two is around
portability so earlier we talked about
all the steps involved a machine
learning framework but that's even that
is just the start then you start to talk
about all the elements in your stack os
drivers runtimes
so on and so forth again it's very very
complicated and to set up even one of
these environments can be very
challenging yet the average data
scientist often faces multiple of these
they might start on their laptop or on a
private rig they might move to a
training solution training cluster and
then finally into the cloud for final
production and and training at scale and
to have a portable solution that works
in all of these places would greatly
speed their ability to work instead of
having to have them set up a custom
bespoke solution for each one and then
finally we get to scalability
scalability is often thought of as just
a number of machines but really in
machine learning it's much more than
that
it's accelerators things like GPUs GPUs
CPUs the speed of your disk and
networking whether or not it's a fixed
disk SSD so on and then it's not just
you know physical assets but it's
actually human beings how do you scale
people with different skill sets
interns SWE's data scientists
researchers IT ops how do you scale
various teams if they're geo-located
even if they're you know sitting right
next to each other but they happen to
have different focuses and ultimately
how do you get more experiments how do
you run them simultaneously and so on so
those are the three things that we think
make up cloud native ml proposed ability
portability and scalability and what we
think is a great solution for that is
containers and kubernetes that's really
what they were designed for loosely
coupling a number of micro services
together and making it very production
ready in scale however if you want to
use machine learning on kubernetes it
can be very challenging there are a lot
of core components that are involved
containers packaging service endpoints
persistent volumes these are often very
new concepts that people are familiar
really with just VMs and discs and even
worse if you get into the data scientist
realm where they really just want to
focus on their experiment yeah I
remember when I first started getting
into containers it was very different
than what I used to do and I actually
started using containers just as kind of
like makeshift VMs not using them to
their full extent and you know first you
have to learn that aspect then you have
to now learn the machine learning or as
you said data scientists just care about
the data yeah absolutely so that's why
we introduced cube flow a way to set up
a complicated but composable portable
machine learning framework in a way
that's that takes advantage of all the
advantages of cloud native machine
learning we want to make it easy for
everyone to develop deploy and manage
portable distributed ml on kubernetes
and it's really important that we
mentioned that last term about focusing
on
Nettie's anywhere there is a kubernetes
deployment this runs great so whether or
not that's Google or on Prem or on
VMware or on other clouds as long as
there is a kubernetes conformant cluster
you can set up and run a cube flow and I
will show you how that works in just a
second the way to think about it is
thinking about back to all those various
stacks we had earlier you have
kubernetes as this base layer you can be
sure that it runs everywhere that's a
core vision of the kubernetes project
then you describe your overall complex
deployment using cube flow native
tooling and you're able to stamp out
cube flow in all of these various
locations and specifically as as Jay
mentioned at cube con EU on Friday we
announced cube flow 0.1 a significant
new milestone for us to get out the door
and start helping people really start to
use production or excuse me
use cube flow in their enterprises to
solve problems today today in the Box we
have Jupiter notebook we have
distributed training in the Box we use
multi framework model serving and I
should really stress right now that
though flow is in the name we really
think about that as machine learning
flow and not tensor flow we support cafe
PI torch and we have lots more
frameworks coming soon our goal is to
really support whatever idata scientists
needs using standard packaging for
customizing it yourself and so with that
I'd like to show you just a very brief
demo about cube flow let me just swap
over here you'll forgive me this was a
live demo this morning but just because
we have to run on this laptop we're
gonna use a recorded video of the one I
did earlier so what you have here is a
standard Yelp analysis excuse me Yelp
sentiment database this is public data
and in the public data basically there's
all the various results from Yelp from
Yelp content and
they have large comment databases and
you're able to see through and page
through all the various information in
this case you have a variety of
different things and and looking at this
middle one it's a lot of words but
really I think as humans we're able to
see that it works properly a little on
the pricey end for baked goods but the
big goods work good also their coffee
products are great these are a lot of
words but clearly as humans were able to
see it however when you apply this to a
standard machine learning framework what
ensued me a standard solution today it
may not look as you know as obviously
correct for these folks you know it's
often very very hard using regular
expression and analysis to have a system
go and look at this so let's actually
try and we hit the prediction in
sentiment and it didn't come back very
well so that's not exactly what we want
to see I think it's actually kind of
funny you know when you think about it
you what you might come up with for a
solution here as well maybe I'll just do
some regular expression matching against
the underlying code and looking at this
regular expression matching you're
looking at it and you're like well
alright you know oh geez someone
commented out good and great we're just
gonna try and find things where it says
annoying terrible and bad you know not
ideal it kind of works but you know
obviously it missed on some of the
things that we were looking for earlier
so what I'd like to do is I'd like to
use machine learning to try and solve
this problem the Google team the Google
brain team as we call them actually I
think that is literally their name
released an open-source machine learning
framework called tensor a tensor that is
a very very well designed Eric's and me
kind of pre-built
for handling a lot of these language
issues and you can see here this is an
entire set of things it describes how to
install and run these various things
which is obviously pretty complicated
but you can see some of the things that
it's really good at it's really good at
things like image language or image
classification language modeling
sentiment analysis and so on and so
really that sentiments in
is what we're gonna try and sit up here
that's just a demo script I'm not
everything we're here is really
happening
that's just demo script to kick
everything off and what we're gonna do
first is we're gonna set up a standard
machine learning framework on your local
cluster using something called mini cube
mini cube is an application that runs on
your laptop and it it creates a
real-life kubernetes cluster running
locally so that you have as little
difference between your laptop and
ultimately what you run in production so
what we're gonna do here is first we're
gonna start using mini cube mini cube is
already running in the background I'm
gonna switch my tube control to point at
that mini cube and then I'm going to run
a deployment of cube flow core that is a
standard package that we have in cube
flow you just execute literally that
command that KS there stands for case in
it and you apply it to mini cube and
what happens immediately is it goes and
deploys all of the various components
that you might want for a core machine
learning framework it gives you tensor
flow it gives you Jupiter hub it gives
you an ambassador for HTTP proxy it
gives you a distributed job framework
and it gives you a dashboard so really
really powerful right out of the box it
gets going and what like I said it
starts up with a Jupiter notebook in
this case accept any username and
passwords hey you don't want to enable
this to the web and did you get it going
but you can see here you're able to go
and select an entire array of various
tools we come with a number of different
packages built-in for running your
kernels whether or not it's CPU or GPU a
whole variety of tensorflow frameworks
and with various notebooks and then it
also allows you to do things like set
the CPU set the memory extra resources
including things like GPUs which is
obviously very very important so with
that we're not going to do an
interactive Jupiter training today we've
already decided to use tensorflow and
it's pretty good so we're gonna do
what's called distributed training
that's where you take that model that
temperature tensor model you
kitten and container and then you're
able you know with this very few amount
of commands and you're able to
distribute it across an entire cluster
and that means that you it's up to you
to now decide how many nodes you want to
use as part of your training so if you
wanted to go faster you could add ten a
hundred a thousand if you wanted to go
slowly or be art you're more
cost-conscious you could use just two or
three so we'll go and we'll do that to
run a distributed training you need to
do one command or you need to do two
things the first thing you need to do is
set some parameters and this is really
where the power of cube flow comes from
or it starts to you highlight first you
saw me set up an entire framework
earlier using a very straightforward
command to select the package that I
want but now I'm able to set parameters
for the specific job that I'm gonna run
without changing any of that underlying
code and these are parameters you
understand you know whether or not
there's a GPU present how many workers
there are where I'm storing my data all
these various things you're able to do
it just like setting any other variable
so I'm setting up them for distributed
training and Here I am I'm kicking off
the with this same command you saw
earlier and kicking off tension or a
tensor which I have built into a
container and just to prove that it is
in fact running here you can see that
the tensor a tensor job is running it's
running in CPUs because I'm only using
my local laptop and I want to have it
run and here you can see you get the
exact same logs that you would run from
any normal tensor flow job with all the
appropriate information there again
nothing special here this is just it I
wouldn't ask you to read this wall of
text I'm just pointing out that this
really is a real live job running and
you saw me execute just you know four or
five commands to get it up off the
ground all right so now that I've done
that you know it's running okay but what
you saw is you didn't see any syntax
errors you know that it ran properly
maybe it converged maybe it didn't
that's okay
all I'm really doing on my local laptop
is making sure that this does run
properly without any air
what I'd like to do now is now that I
said hey this does run great I'd like to
take it to a cluster in the cloud to run
that training very very quickly and so
in this case I've set up a gke google
kubernetes engine cluster it runs on on
Google cloud obviously and it's going to
run with two different sets of nodes
first it's going to run with GPU nodes
and those are the the absolute latest
went from Nvidia with a whole variety of
different nodes and node poles you can
see here that we're using 8 Nvidia Tesla
P 100 accelerators attached to those
nodes and then second we're also going
to use the brand new T Pugh's from
Google up let me just do that you can
see the p1 hundreds there and second
we're gonna use the TP use those are the
tensor processing units attached to the
same cluster and we're gonna run those
jobs simultaneously across those
clusters to see which one runs first
sometimes p1 hundreds run better
sometimes TP use run better it doesn't
matter to us week because we have it's
so easy to set up multiple of these we
can run the experiment ourselves and you
can see here this is what the TPS look
like and they support tensorflow version
1.7 so we'll make sure to support that
in our notes ok so now that we've kicked
it off we're going to run this and now
we're going to switch to that cluster
that I just showed you and we're gonna
apply that exact same deployment that I
ran locally and again this is part of
the power of cube flow I don't have to
make big changes in fact in this case
I'm making no changes from the exact
same deployment I had locally I'm able
to deploy to my gke cluster that makes
it easy for me to get started easy for
me to have reproducible machine learning
and data science and you can see they're
updating it in the cluster on the cloud
next I'm going to kick off my GPU
training again I'm gonna use that same
package that I had built earlier for
running on my
lokah machine that was running again
CPUs but this time I'm gonna change the
parameters and say no in fact I do have
GPUs on these nodes and I want you to
pick it up and then I'm also gonna
change here where the data is stored and
again I'm doing that based on parameters
not changing code and I apply those and
those should be kicked off momentarily
second I'm also going to deploy that to
TP use and so again I'm going to change
the I'm gonna change a parameter to make
sure that this new job is running
against TP use and I'm also going to use
a slightly different build unfortunately
today you have to build different
versions based on whether or not you're
using GPUs and CPUs again for data
scientists this is great because it
means you're able to package and
describe exactly how you want that model
to run okay
so we're kicking that off as well this
time I don't have to go into my local
logs to do it because google kubernetes
engine actually has a great UI for me to
explore what jobs are running
simultaneously so here you can see all
the logs the current loss rate it's
happening very quickly it's saving
checkpoints into that Google Storage
bucket and you can see here all the
various jobs that are running
simultaneously okay so the jobs are
kicked off they're running again we're
not going to bore you with how long it
takes to run all these I'm gonna use in
fact tensor board and in this case
tensor board
also ships with team flow it's built in
and it shows you how quickly things are
stepping through the overall process and
how quickly things are resolving great
UI and it helps your data scientists
really debug and and understand what's
going on under the hood and most
importantly it ships in the Box you saw
literally exactly what you saw earlier
is what's running now I didn't have to
do any special new packaging or
distributions to run this and yet it ran
great on my laptop it ran great on GPUs
and CPUs and in this case we're able to
see roughly speaking about sixteen and a
half steps per second for the TP use and
you saw earlier about three steps per
second for the GPUs so in one command
I'm able to test again
multiple different accelerators and in
this case the TPS came out about five
times faster really really powerful
stuff and we're really really excited to
show you and then finally like I said
the demo needs to be short so we'll try
and jump forward here a little bit also
included in the cube flow box I promise
you know it's not unlimited but there's
a lot of stuff in there is tensorflow
surfing so in this case you have
tensorflow serving which means we're
gonna take that trained bottle and we're
actually gonna be able to serve it and
attach it to that yelp review you saw
earlier we deploy that serving and now
we're going to excuse me we're gonna
swap over you can see here in the google
kubernetes engine UI that tensors the
tensor de temps are serving is running
and it ready to receive results so we'll
go back to our yelp review this is a
different web page that is now designed
to use ml here were the original results
all wrong one that was happy when it
should been sad one that was sad when it
should have been happy and the final one
that was happy when it should been sad
and we're gonna reattach that swap back
over and go over to the UI and hit the
predicts sentiment again and it now
comes out correct and so that's really
the summary of cube flow it's a very
very straightforward framework that
really empowers you to make decisions
about machine the best machine learning
framework for you without having to
worry about any of this stuff under the
hood yeah I mean that's definitely
that's I mean seems like it's leaps and
bounds for machine learning cuz I can
like you show with mini cube run the
cluster on my machine and whether it be
servers in a Colo or servers in my
office or even a cloud Google cloud I
can just move it and continue running my
models with more power and then of
course it comes packaged with all those
great little tools like tensor board
absolutely and and that really is it
when you go and talk to almost any data
scientist in the world today they often
have very dispersed environments that
they'll need to run in they want to be
moved where
the data is they may have petabytes of
data that they want to process and that
may not be in this cloud or that cloud
and what they're really looking to do is
get to an environment where they can
think clearly about the model and and
let the separation and IT ops you know
take care of it for that awesome what
you didn't see there were some really
important points first you didn't see
any bespoke solutions these weren't you
know custom new ML frameworks they
weren't brand new open-source solutions
we're using existing very popular open
source technologies today that you can
use or swap out for your own things
aren't like insanely tightly wired
together second you didn't see any cloud
specific technology
even when we were deploying to Google
kubernetes engine we were using this
exact same software that we had running
locally all we did was swap out of
parameters and then finally you didn't
see any forking of the kubernetes api
meaning anywhere you have a kubernetes
compliant cluster it's gonna run great
and really this is gonna empower a
brand-new set of it data scientists and
other people in the world there's a
great story out of sweden where a group
of scientists were able to look at a
number of data and identify that what
they were doing wrong was they were
plowing the wrong streets at the wrong
time and stay-at-home parents and women
who happen to not be at work that day
ended up being injured far more
frequently because in light snow
situations they would be tripping and
falling on sidewalks when cars could
actually handle wet so by looking at the
data scientists and using frameworks
just like cute flow they were able to
see that they could make a huge impact
in people's lives without any change or
any other budget just by changing the
order and that's really what we need to
do as far as using cue flow it's really
empowering everyone at the various
levels to make smart decisions and help
them you know make the world a better
place and by doing that by focusing on
giving people clean layers by giving the
data scientists the ability to make
these decisions they're able to hand off
to the next
them to make even better decisions and
really change the world we are just
getting started with cube flow it is 0.1
it's a little early for running in
production even though all the
components of cube flow are
battle-tested things like tensor flow as
I mentioned in tensor board Jupiter and
things like that have been out for many
many months cube flow is still brand new
but we do have a lot of people helping
you can see a small subset of people who
are contributing to the platform today
and then what's next in tupelo 0.2 which
we have hoping to have out by this
summer we're gonna make it even easier
to set it up
integrate with more and deeper
kubernetes features and a lot better
packages but really the feature we'd
like to have is the one we haven't heard
yet there are many many data scientists
out there that are trying to solve the
problem and cube flow is entirely an
open-source project we it is though
Google contributed to is significantly
we have over 70 contributors from 17
different companies working on it today
and we want to make sure it truly does
run everywhere and so if you find that
there is a machine learning problem that
you're running into today we would love
to hear about it
we're on github so exactly and so with
that that's a wrap you know like I said
we we have all the various places for us
to reach out and I think we're going to
take just a moment to collect the
questions
you
all right we're back so let's go into
some questions here what does the
adoption of cube flow look like in the
wild so the reality is I wasn't I wasn't
joking q flow is a zero point one
release right now we would actually not
recommend using it in too many
production workloads right now that said
we have heard many many stories and you
can go and check out the cube float org
website coming soon not quite available
yet or our github repo to see a number
of places that people are using it today
in the examples directory you will
already see a great number of examples
there a solution around github
summarization github issue summarization
temp sort of tensor is obviously built
in and a number of other ones where you
can download and start experimenting
with Q flow today awesome so this cube
flow run on gke absolutely so the demo
that you saw there was a cube flow
running on google kubernetes engine and
it obviously runs great and it takes
advantage of all the elements that are
available in google cloud node pools
preemptable vm's GPUs GPUs so on and so
forth but like I said it really does run
anywhere on Google
excuse me kubernetes runs and so that
might be another cloud or on Prem but
obviously we think that you know we can
do a pretty good job serving cube flow
on gke of course oh here's a very
interesting one when would I use cube
flow over Google Cloud ml engine
absolutely all right so this is a
question we get a lot and the reality is
is a cloud machine learning engine is
fantastic we strongly recommended what
we have found though is that oftentimes
a data scientist might want to swap out
or need something in a hybrid or
on-premise solution and in those cases
that's when you would want to swap out
so basically the summary is if you'd
like a hosted solution where you really
don't have to think about anything under
the hood you just want to hand a model
to something and get back an answer or
use it for inference cloud machine
learning is fantastic and we would
strongly recommend it if you have
customization or you want to do
on-premises or you want to do a hybrid
scenario cube flow would be your best
they're really do a layer over each
other very nicely right so right tool
for the right job kind of thing
absolutely if I am ml data scientist
how will cube flow simplify my daily
life rather than complicate it by adding
the kubernetes layer absolutely um you
know I think one of the biggest things
here is that a lot of data scientists
really want to operate at that next
level up I mean I can't tell you how
many data scientists I was just talking
with a fantastic researcher last week
who literally couldn't reproduce their
experiment from a year ago because the
versions of Python had changed and they
weren't sure what happened in their
library dependencies that failed tube
flow allows you to describe your entire
framework in a containerized
hermetically sealed dropped in amber
kind of scenario and and really detail
it forever and so that's something that
you can share with your colleagues you
can put in a research paper all those
various things and it means you also
don't have to solve all the problems
under the hood you don't have to deal
with service discovery you don't have to
deal with provisioning persistent disk
you don't have to deal with attaching
drivers and GPUs and things like that
kubernetes takes care of all that stuff
for you now that said if you are just
experimenting and you want to use a
single you know we call it kitchen sink
container that could be perfectly fine
what we found though is more often than
not what happens is that immediately
following that experiment a data
scientist has to completely rewrite
their entire model completely rewrite
all their dependencies and set up and
and have a lot of trouble even
reproducing the experiments they were
doing in the first place because that
that experiment that they were running
initially is no longer production-ready
and that's where we hope to make a lot
of distant distance with cube flow
kubernetes is very very easy to set up
it comes in docker it has mini cube as
set up and then you can deploy it you
can describe and deploy your entire
framework of cube flow onto that local
cluster and that is a production ready
solution that's something you can take
elsewhere it's very good yes kubernetes
that there's a little bit of a learning
curve with it but it's pretty easy to
set up and again it's much easier as you
mentioned control versus learning
how to manage yo more apt repository and
get all the right dependency and
everything so yeah I mean the the demo
you saw today was totally you know live
real demo and you saw no kubernetes
commands literally none other than just
to show off you know that something was
actually running they all the systems
for running and trying your model were
built in and not that data science layer
that you're all familiar with alright it
looks like we've got one more question
here what about data and model
versioning absolutely that's something
that's very actively being discussed in
the cube flow community right now we
have heard this request a lot this is
something where we really do want to
empower the community to make these
decisions and help think about what
should come in the box and what isn't
kin float isn't trying to solve a lot of
these problems we're really packaging
the best-of-breed that's out there today
and so in many of those discussions that
are happening right now in the cloud or
excuse me in the community you are
seeing folks begin to to come up with
some norms about what data and model
versioning should look like and when
those norms land we will ask people who
want to participate in those discussions
to snap to those norms which basically
say hey you know if you're gonna run a
machine-learning or excuse me a model
version or a data versioning pipeline
you should do one two three four and as
long as any solution comes along and
does one two three four it should run
fine well that's great well thank you
David so much for joining us and telling
everybody about the wonders of coop flow
hopefully we can get some people to
start using it and start contributing in
we want to see all those pull requests
coming into github so and all he also
hear your success stories so it's
definitely been great to have you
absolutely thank you so much well thank
you very much for watching and please
tune into Tuesday's cloud on air next
week in every following week
you